dear president Ruto
for hosting this Africa climate Summit
and thank you very much for your
leadership on climate action ever
since you took office
I very much welcome
Kenya's climate change act 2023 that was
launched during this Summit
and that puts strong emphasis on carbon
markets
we fully support you on this important
topic
presidents
Prime Ministers fellow leaders
excellencies
I want to greet my colleague musafaki
chairman of the African Union
I want to greet the president asumani
from the comoros I want to read
Secretary General Antonio Gutierrez Dr
Sultan Al javera president of the cop 28
my fellow leaders ladies and gentlemen
I am deeply honored to participate in
this discussion
this Summit is a crucial step to prepare
the upcoming cop 28 meeting
and to make sure that Africa's voice
resonates around the world
and that Africa's priorities
as a continent that is most affected by
climate change
are duly taken on board
today I'm here not only to listen to you
but also to bring Europe's offer
to be your ally at cup 28.
and to work together
on all issues on the agenda
because however different our two
continents may look
we share the same interests when it
comes to climate action
we hear you president Ruto
and dear friends when you say that
Africa's first priority is to grow your
economy yes and lift as many people as
possible out of poverty yes you're so
right
climate action
is part of the solution
you are part of the solution
with your huge potential for renewable
energy and clean hydrogen
your critical raw materials
your incredible nature and biodiversity
and your young Workforce
you can help clean up Global Energy
Systems and Supply chains
why are you creating good jobs here
and economic opportunities yet that your
people demand rightly so
this is a win-win partnership
which benefits Africa
and the world
for instance the benefits of expanding
Africa's clean energy sector would be
massive
by speeding up the transition to solar
and wind power
energy sector jobs in Africa could
double in a few years
and Africa could produce enough clean
energy not only
power up your continent but also to
export abroad
climate action
can be one of the my main drivers of
Africa's growth
but for this
Africa needs massive investment
and Europe wants to be your partner
wants to be your partner in closing this
investment Gap
first of all we fully support the need
for multi-development multilateral
Development Bank reform
it is time to move from words to action
absolutely
secondly investment has to come
and this is why 150 billion Euro in our
investment plan are designated
for Africa we call it global gateway
they are aimed at the African continent
global gateway supports Investments
ranging from hydropower plants in the
DRC Burundi Ronda and Tanzania
to the 1 billion Euro initiative on
climate adaptation and resilience in
Africa which we announced at cop 27.
and global gateway is unique
in the global investment landscape
we're not only interested in extracting
resources we want to partner with you
to create local value chains to create
good jobs here in Africa we want to
share European technology with you
we want to invest in skills for local
workers this is crucial for the young
people
because
the stronger you are as suppliers
the more Europe will diversify Supply
Supply chains towards Africa and the
more we both will de-risk our economies
it's a clear win-win
Namibia for instance is now building a
new hydrogen industry
as well as rare
materials value chains in partnership
with Europe
and later this morning president Ruto
and I will conclude a new hydrogen
partnership between Kenya and the
European Union
with the objective to further develop
the green hydrogen economy and with a
full support of Team Europe this is good
news for Africa and for Europe alike so
we should work very closely as partner
yet
public money from major economies
however crucial
is not enough
and this is why we need to bring the
conversation on climate financing
to the global stage at cup 28. let me
briefly Share three specific points that
will be discussed here in Nairobi to
pave the way towards cop 28. first on
attracting private investment to Africa
second on carbon pricing and carbon
credits and third on setting Global
targets for the energy transition
on the first point
the green transition will require an
unprecedented scale of private
investment
Public Finance will not surface
this is true for Europe
but it is also true for emerging market
and developing economies
private Capital will need to be
mobilized at scale
and here
green bonds are widely recognized as
providing part of the solution
this is why we just put forward a new
proposal to attract private investment
called Global green bonds initiative
we know that emerging economies can face
hurdles to access Capital markets
but we can change that together
Europe has the biggest and most advanced
green bond market in the world so we are
ready to share our expertise with your
teams on how to develop your own green
Bond markets and at the same time
we will push on the Investor's side
together with the European Investment
Bank and our member states
we are allocating 1 billion euros to
de-risk private investments in Emerging
Markets
this could help to attract up to 20
billion euros in sustainable investment
so
let's work together on that
to build and grow Africa's green Bond
markets and let us bring together this
crucial point to cup 28.
there's another solution that would
unlock huge resources for climate action
in Africa
and that is carbon pricing
and true carbon credits
and this is my second point
I believe as you do president Ruto that
setting a price on carbon emissions
is one of the most efficient
and one of the most effective Tools in
our hands
because it Fosters Innovation by the
private sector that's crucial
because it makes heavy polluters pay a
fair price that is necessary
and because it creates revenues that can
support the clean transition in
developing countries
that's what we need
and this includes also
to include the carbon sinks that have
been mentioned and you are rich in
carbon things here and to reward this
contribution we have to get there
we will discuss this in more detail in
the next session so let us work together
to bring a proposal for Global carbon
pricing and true carbon credits at cop
28.
and finally
on global energy goals
if we are to limit global warming to 1.5
degrees
we have to speed up the global energy
transition
that means if we want to match our goals
we need to Triple renewable energy
capacity
and we need to double Energy Efficiency
by 2030.
this sounds bold
but it is doable
if we Step Up Global investment
in Renewables this would make clean
energy more affordable for all countries
including here in Africa
and this is why cop 28 president Dr
Sultan al-jabbar and I
Champion an Initiative for Global
targets for the energy transition to be
achieved collectively
because only what gets measured gets
done so the global goals will provide a
benchmark to track the progress
and to attract even more private
investment
so I look forward to working with you on
this and much much more
I hope that Africa and Europe will join
forces
to reach a global agreement at cop 28
ladies and gentlemen
these three proposals may look old they
may look impossible to achieve
but in the beautiful words of Nelson
Mandela who said
it always seems impossible until it's
done
we have a huge responsibility to fight
climate change for the good of our
children
father God of our grandchildren and I
wrote down these beautiful words of the
African youth yesterday
our countries are burning and drowning
as you are not here to save us we have
to trust you now so my friends let's
reward the trust of these young people
and show responsibility let's join
forces for cop 28. many things I feel so
honored for being invited thank you